Hi and welcome to the Neil Ashton
podcast. In each episode, we explain
some of the fascinating ways that
[music] science and engineering are
changing the world around us. We talk to
leading engineers from elite level
sports like cycling and Formula 1 to
some of the world's top academics to
understand how fluid dynamics, machine
learning, supercomputing are bringing
[music] in a new era of discovery. We
also hear some of their life stories,
their career advice, and lessons they've
learned on the way that I hope will be
helpful to you, too. So, sit back and
enjoy this episode.
Hi, welcome back to the Neil Ashton
podcast. So, as the title of this uh
episode suggests, I've changed jobs.
I've left Nvidia and I'm joining uh
Mistral. I wanted to use this episode to
talk a little bit more about the reasons
for doing it but but more than that go
into talking a little bit more from a
career progression point of view uh
career advice point of view um I've done
episodes in the past you know which have
tried to give some guidance to people
who are maybe early on in their careers
uh just after university or first jobs
uh and I thought it might be useful a
time to reflect and and maybe give some
things I've learned uh along the way and
to briefly talk about some of the sort
of reasons for me doing it. Um this is
in no way a sort of commercial thing.
I'm not trying to sell you to to to
Mistral. Um I just in the in
transparency I I think this actually
might be useful for some people to know.
So just I guess to get out the the
obvious bit which is what am I actually
doing? What what have I done? So I've um
I joined Mr. as well as the VP of
computational engineering where I'll be
co-leading the AI for engineering side
of things with my very good friend
Johannes who I'll talk a bit uh about
later on and uh and yeah it's um to
summarize it very briefly it's about
developing uh physics AI so foundation
models all the stuff that you know we
talked about in the fluid intelligence
paper um and also the LLM uh side of
things and and to be completely
transparent, one of the reasons I was so
excited to to go to a company like
Mistrial was to be
right there where these leading LLMs are
being developed. And for me, it's an
amazing opportunity to to learn and
contribute and to to make an impact in
that. And that is yeah, super exciting.
I'm not going to talk any more uh on on
this for now. Um also, like I said,
really want this to be more of a sort of
general thing. I'm not here to try and
sell uh the company. You know, you can
there'll be opportunities for that on
more the official sort of uh I guess
mistral channels, etc. Um but this I'd
like to maybe take a step back a little
bit and um and give you idea of sort of
how I got to that and what drove some of
the decisions. Uh but maybe for some of
you who are um like I said earlier on in
your career and this might be some
useful things. So I I guess this started
I did a 4-year mast's engineering um at
Manchester University and probably like
many of you I really wasn't sure what I
wanted to do. I'd got to the end of a
degree
and didn't know what I wanted to
specialize in. Didn't really know what
company I wanted to be at. This was the
days before LinkedIn. you know I am
getting a bit old now just turned over
40 in fact been 41 soon so I guess this
is a while ago and so things are
probably different now uh but back then
uh certainly it wasn't I mean obvious
you know what companies to go to you
know just graduate schemes or going to
um emailing or people etc. It was quite
different uh back then compared to now
and um I had been lucky to do a
placement with a uh racing team. So
Formula 1 was for sure on my mind. I was
lucky enough in um to do my fourth year
project with this team called Iceport
International that was a Formula 2 team.
So the sort of feeder series to Formula
1 at that time called GP2.
and I was doing a project to help
optimize their rear wing in a wind
tunnel and to do some CFD was actually
my first introduction to CFD using I
think Gambit for anybody who is a CFD
person will remember that tool from many
years ago and fluent and I more than
anything the amazing opportunity was to
go to the racetrack. So I actually
shadowed a fantastic engineer called
Gavin. Um, and if if Gavin's listening,
I really should bring him on this
podcast. I'd love to talk to her about
all those years. Uh, and shadowed and
was like a shadow race engineer. I mean,
shadowing in the most thing of it. I
wasn't doing that much. Uh, but I was
there watching how do they set up the
car? How do they decide what to do with
a strategy? I was sat on the pit wall uh
trying to lift up the signs. Uh, it was
an unbelievable experience for someone
21. I think uh at that time also this
for people's interest uh Christian her
was at that time in Formula 2 he owned
the art Grand Prix team um if I remember
correctly I remember seeing him at some
of the races and Teemo Glock was racing
for iceport who later of course had that
controversial thing in Formula 1 that
racing moment you had Bruno Senna of
course Eton Senna's nephew and um Karen
Chandok who now does a lot of commentary
on TV. Uh Luca Degrassi was also around
at that time I think with art and um
and who else was there and yeah several
other uh people that I'm um forgetting.
It was a great experience. It definitely
made me think right I want to get into
Formula 1. Um I think I've told this
story before but I emailed I think
basically every Formula 1 team. Didn't
get any response. I didn't know anybody.
Had no clue. I was probably not even
emailing the right person. I don't think
they even had the email addresses on the
website. It just felt like an
impenetrable thing. [gasps]
And um so for that and linked to various
other things, I'd got into the research
side. I was given the opportunity to do
a PhD and uh as I explained to people
doing a PhD basically was do you want to
carry on being a student but be paid and
do it around potentially formula 1 theme
to thing. So, I took that opportunity
and I'll I'll skip through I won't go
chronologically through every year or
it's going to take forever. Uh but um
during the course of PhD, I finally felt
like I knew what I wanted to go into. I
knew that I could be a CFD or
computational engineering specialist.
That felt [snorts] clearer, which is why
I always I'm an advocate of doing a PhD
because I feel it gives you time to know
what you'd want to do. you could do lots
of other things. Um, in fact, you could
argue the reason I'm doing this podcast
now is because when I was at university
during my PhD,
I ended up being um the like subeditor
of the newspaper for the university. I
got in to journalism. I got into writing
and explaining uh things. Something that
I didn't do in my undergrad and probably
if I'd have left at the undergrad and
gone straight into a job, I probably
wouldn't have done it. The PhD gave me
that sort of time. also gave me a lot of
time to meet people and go to
conferences. I was involved in a lot of
these European workshops, you know, with
EDF Energy, with France, um, with
Airbus, with DR and it was a great, uh,
experience and Alistair Revel who was my
super at the time I owe a lot who sort
of showed me that that world and and but
as my good friend Alistister West and
probably remembers, we I remember saying
to him, if I ever say that I want to do
a posttock, please like you know stop
me. By the end of the PhD I was just
like not interested in academia. I just
wanted to get out. Uh wanted to get a
job. I had no desire to do academia.
And luckily because of the PhD
I'd now I think become a sort of
specialist I guess and I tried again to
get a job in Formula 1. Emailed all the
teams. Basically nobody replied apart
from um two or three teams. Did a few
interviews. Uh a couple I was going into
like aerodynamics which wasn't really my
thing. Went to one which was Lotus.
Applied for an aerodynamics position.
Basically they realized that I wasn't an
aerodynamicist but the the gentleman
Jared
said oh but maybe we could create you a
position to be a CFD engineer
and uh you know we'll do it for 6 months
or and then if you know if you do well
we'll we'll we'll we'll carry on and um
and that was that was my break and so I
have to thank Jared a lot for that.
Jared's now I think the chief engineer
of Mercedes F1 team or I mean he's very
very senior. He basically I think looks
after all of the car development arrow.
Um I haven't seen him for a good few
years. Uh but he he gave me that that
that break and so yeah I left sort of
left university behind and went into
there. Um
then only after leaving academia did I
reflect that I actually missed it and I
realized that
even though I really enjoyed doing the
Formula 1 job
I felt because I've been doing aerospace
and I had so much freedom
and I felt that I was just getting into
a more like dayto-day job there
something didn't fully connect. Uh and
so this is why I sometimes give this
advice now that
don't rule out something. Sometimes you
need time to leave to realize that you
like it. So it was only leaving academia
or leaving after the PhD to go to
industry that made me sort of realize
the benefits of of academia. And so sure
enough, I went back to do a posttock,
the thing that I said I would never do,
leaving Formula 1 behind, but thinking
to myself,
it's not like I'm closing the door
forever, but I feel I want to become
even more of a specialist. I felt good
after my PhD, but ironically, going into
Formula 1 changed my mind. I was like,
ah, this is how industry does it. All
the stuff in academia was great in my
PhD, but I realized I'd been, you know,
not naive, but I hadn't really
understood how the world works. Going
into Formula 1 and industry, maybe got
ah I think I can now come up with a
research direction. I think I know what
my research could fix. So I went back to
do the posttock uh at at Manchester
and uh I actually did it also with CD
Adapt which is now Seammens and that was
another entry point into the software
side. So I actually had a great
opportunity to work with the team at
City of Appco in Hammersmith in London.
Would go down there sometimes and that
again exposed me to the sort of ISV
software world and during the post talk
it was great because then I would really
be going to conferences expanding my
network uh even more and that was when I
had the opportunity to
then eventually move to to Oxford
University. uh that was a great
opportunity where then I really started
to specialize more in HPC
uh and that's sort of where all my high
performance computing sort of uh an IT I
guess you would call it side came in uh
to to to everything and that's the other
thing that I'd advise is that changing
university if you're an academic is good
there's no doubt if you just stay at one
institution your whole time yes you can
do it but I think it does change your
mindset so that's sort of second piece
of advice I guess the first one being
it's okay to switch between industry and
academia and the second one being even
within academia it's probably good to
change institutions to see a different
world to see a different attitude so I
had a great time in the Wes Amore who's
now a professor uh in the engineering
science department was fantastic for me
and um and actually that was my
opportunity then to go to to NASA
because I'd met um Chattin Chatir who
was at that I'm the branch chief at NASA
as he he kind of saw that I had this
experience industrial experience from
Formula 1 which I kind of been bringing
in to my research thinking how can we
solve some of these problems and he
invited me over I think at the same time
Jeff Slopnik uh who has now retired from
Boeing invited me over to to Boeing to
give a talk to them because I think they
had a link with F1 anyway and that
opened up my world to the US And I've
said this before, but this is I've
noticed with academia
there is like quite often
it's almost like a European way of doing
thing in the US. I don't know if this
translates outside of CFD, but everybody
in Europe that there was this
well maybe not Europe, but certainly the
UK. Oh no, I think more Europe. There
was it was coming from like this
incompressible
maybe it wasn't so much an aircraft
design. it was. So I think that's where
open film came out of Imperial very much
with this sort of incompressible
pressure-based segregated type
approaches. Um and that was true at
Manchester with the EDF, a lot of the
codes were like that. And then you'd go
and even if I look at the curriculum
that we had, the examples were with
those sort of formulations. And then you
go to the US and it was all because a
lot of it was done through NASA and
Boeing and aerospace. you were taught at
Stanford and others more in like
compressible density based uh codes and
I remember and like overset meshes and
all these things I'd never come across
before. Uh and that really opened my
eyes and it was the first time I saw
Silicon Valley and ironically I remember
being out in Silicon Valley and thinking
oh wow wouldn't it be amazing to come
and work here. That was 2016 so 10 years
ago. Um
uh and I'm sorry if this is boring
people but I'm going to keep going cuz I
I'm hoping this is also the reason like
if you do a posttock you can also try
and find those placement opportunities
you can find go somewhere expand your
horizon go to a different part of the
world just to see do they do things
differently uh there and then um you
know I I came back to the to the UK kept
you know trying to push things um that
was I started to do also a little bit of
consulting with um with Williams and and
Audi and and uh British cycling team. Um
ended up doing then some stuff for
Formula 1 because um good friend of mine
James James Crook um sort of helped
introduce me. It's a bit of a long
story, but um basically they needed some
help to be doing the um the 2022 uh
regulations at that time and they were
looking to build up like a CFD team. Um
and uh you know, I sort of pitched that
I could do the CFD for them. In reality,
you know, it probably didn't make sense
for them. And so I think they went with
um with Total Sim, you know, who have
become good good friends, but they were
like, well, maybe you could just help us
as like a consultant, as an adviser. You
know, CFD, you can and HBC, you could
maybe stop, give us advice so we know
what we're doing. Uh, and so that that
was an amazing opportunity to go back
into F1
um quite a few years later except now
I'm in London with Pat Simmons, you
know, an icon of the sport, somebody
who, you know, I speak with now
reasonably regularly and someone I
greatly admire as one of the sort of
amazing brains of the the sport who,
yeah, totally gets it, has a very
forward uh looking and it was a bit of
um a shell shock to be uh in F1 in
London with him, Jason uh Somerville
who's now deputy technical director at
Alpine, Simon Dodman who's now one of
the chief engineers at at Cadillac um
and and a couple of other people uh and
uh and sat in London and Ross Brawn's
walking around cuz his office is
basically like right next to you. It was
very surreal to be to be doing it. Um,
and um, it I'm sort of saying this
because I never knew that I would work
for AWS or Nvidia or any of these. I
thought I would always be just like a
CFD person. And and funny enough, during
Formula 1, they sponsored AWS
or AWS sponsored Formula 1. And at that
time, they were like, "Okay, well, we
kind of need somebody who can help us
maybe on this cloud stuff." And because
I got that HPC background from moving to
Oxford, you know, I ended up helping
basically on the HBC side. And uh and
and I've sort of told this story a few
times, but I ended up then also
AWS said, would you mind helping us? Uh
and and you know, Formula 1 were
completely fine with it. So I I was sort
of helping both people at the same time.
um which which was really kind of a
funny situation but it was all done with
complete transparency. It was basically
like hey can you help the AWS people who
weren't CFD specialist help formula one
to get all the CFD going and work with
you know total sim and others and um and
I remember there was like one example
where the code wouldn't scale that we
thought it was because of the
interconnect at the time being slow on
on the cloud you know the whole like EFA
thing getting into too much details for
most people but if you're a HPC
personally you know this is a big
controversy Ethernet Infinibad and they
thought ah it's because it's Ethernet.
So we we basically why should we do this
deal with AWS? You know, the performance
is crap. And uh and turns out I found
out it was uh due to a mesh
decomposition. They were using
uh hierarchical instead of scotch and I
said let's switch to scotch because I'd
done some research in the past that
shows it scales better. Very very
specific thing but basically it showed
that then you could scale a and that
helped a lot the AWS people. I work with
a great guy Lewis Foti on that and and
basically long story short the reason
I'm blabbing on about this is because
that is when AWS said to me would you
like a role at AWS you could be our CTF
specialist because we've seen how you've
been able to sort of translate and help
formula 1 to AWS well we want to go to
all these other engineering companies
could you be our like you know domain
specialist
and there there it was there was my
opportunity to completely change to go
essentially back into industry. It was a
very difficult decision to leave Oxford
at that time. I was still just starting
to get to the point of being offered
like a faculty position. Um it I'm not
going to be I'm not going to lie to you.
It was a struggle. Um I didn't really
succeed in academia. Like I see some
people getting a professorship straight
away. I I don't know. Maybe my research
area just wasn't aligned. I was too
industrial. But um I took that very
difficult choice to to leave and you
know to go to the dark side to go to
industry and there it was I joined AWS
uh an unbelievable experience in the
cloud and it was great because I've
always been a sort of IT person. I did
an IT A level when I was 14. I was a bit
of a geek and so I I got to to do that
and those years at AWS
were probably the most transformative in
terms of working at a you know 100,000
or million person company being in these
commercial discussions understanding the
sales cycle and the technical cycle like
just amazing um and um and throughout
that time I just learned so much I I but
I kept with academia I kept publishing I
kept doing workshops. Um this whole auto
CFD thing I started at Oxford. I carried
on carried on publishing papers.
I've always kept that academic mindset.
Uh and it was a couple of years in that
I I wanted to go back even more
technical and so I moved from the sales
side which is basically where solution
architects were into the product
engineering team at AWS.
and Deborah who's my manager and Ian
colleague were were fantastic for that
and I I then got into like how do you
design
a service I saw this how does the
product team work how does the
engineering team work how do you do
monthly business reviews how do you
design the APIs how do you figure out
the needs what's going to be the revenue
what's going to be the structure of the
code how are we going to make this a SAS
solution what are going to be the
compute requirements EC2 oh my god like
sitting in those calls with Dave Brown
who I really liked. I think he's now
just gone to Meta to lead all their
infrastructure. I just unbelievable
experience. I can't tell you going to
all these big tech companies how much
you learn. Just I can't think I would be
where I am now without having made that
switch to to to AWS. And that's when I
got into machine learning. I was for
years kicking off sort of and I probably
shouldn't talk too much about it openly
just to say there was projects I was um
leading where I really got in to machine
learning uh the surrogate modeling in a
huge way was like so much of my time and
that's actually where the drive ML stuff
was created these open data sets because
I knew that we wanted to develop things
and test things and um we needed open
data and it was my academic IC mind I
could have created that data and kept it
internal but I thought no it's the best
thing for the community that the entire
community benefits it will help us as
well if everything so and I think it has
you put the data out it's now become one
of the most widely used data sets and it
has helped all tech companies to to
advance so uh and that was something I
did with a ML and winter ML and and I
really it taught me I truly believe open
source helps everybody
Um
but
I
felt like if I really wanted to succeed
in the sort of AI for engineering, you
know, do I need to to keep moving on? Is
there other opportunities? And this is
where I had the, you know, great
opportunity most recently with Nvidia. I
joined to sort of do a not a completely
dissimilar role to AWS to be that I
guess domain specialist for for CE now.
I I sort of broadened out and eventually
also to EDA and joining Nvidia
again I felt like another step just
amazing
to see all of the stuff around the GPU
development, the CPU development, um all
the the AI development with like Neotron
and Vix Nemo, the way Jensen runs the
company just like incredible
just like another level, you know. Also
I guess I was slightly biased to AD as
always thinking the cloud going to
Nvidia. Then you you saw the other side
you know that there is this obviously
huge onrem opportunity. I saw now this
in between you know like these neo
clouds etc. Um but also loved getting
into the architecture. It wasn't my main
job but seeing how they make the
decisions on okay what should be the
next GPU? How do we decide this? How do
we, you know, all the benchmark that
goes on the, I can't tell you how many
super smart people there are at NVIDIA,
it's [snorts] nuts. Um, then all of the
CUDA libraries, all the stuff that goes
in at the lower level, you know, the
these enabling libraries that you
basically most people don't know about,
but are what powers all of deep learning
and engineering. [snorts] So, I I was
fortunate to still sort of help with
some of the sales side as well, speaking
to customers. um uh and and the AI side
and the agentic and then working with
some of the chip design team at NVIDIA
on the EDA side. But probably one of the
biggest things I realized at Nvidia was
the partnerships. I totally and I think
this is a Jensen thing the value of the
ecosystem and partnerships and I learned
so much from interacting with cadence
and synopsis and seammens and you know
I've realized the value of the the
ecosystem you know that it's not one
company can do everything it's a
multi-layered
uh cake and um and that that was an
experience that I sort of saw at AWS but
it was turbocharged
uh at at Nvidia and and Uh again I if id
have stayed at AWS no way would I have
the knowledge that I have now. Not this
is nothing against AWS amazing company
just like Azure and GCP and all the
cloud providers but I definitely felt
like I learned so much for Nvidia and to
the point that I was absolutely not you
know looking to leave. I was very happy
um you know that that those
inspirational uh figures there you know
I had I had a great manager. I was so
inspired by people like Ian Buck and um
and and Madison and and Carrie and all
these sort of and Reb and all these like
great leaders, you know. It was so
so good, you know, just felt like every
day I was learning. But I definitely
felt like I could take another step.
That's for sure. Um and when the
opportunity when you know sort of
Johannes was like you've got to come.
You've got to come over. You know this
was Emmy just got acquired by Mistral.
It's like this is it. We can do it
together. Let's let's this is the new
wave, right? It's the Frontier Lab
company um with Physics AI and you know
I really deliberated on it um because as
I said you know I I love Nvidia I still
do today I think it's an amazing company
but I thought this is it. I've never
done a startup, you know, as you saw
from me talking about the history. I've
done academia, gone to AWS, gone to
Nvidia, sold two very big companies. I
thought, oh, maybe going to a thousand
person company. Yes, I can take a bit of
more ownership as well. That's, you
know, obviously I'll be transparent. You
know, becoming a VP, it's it's a nice
thing. It's a nice great progression. Uh
being part of a sort of leadership team,
but it was still my inner academic
scientist wanted to learn. And having
the opportunity to get into this space
of LLMs,
I felt this for sure no matter what
happens, I will learn a lot. It will
always help you know my understanding
and uh and so yeah I I made the move. I
made the move out of a desire to
to learn more I guess and a feel like to
build something. I should say that's the
other thing is that for very good
reasons Nvidia and AWS still stay at the
say not the top level of the stack you
know um they're not making an
application per se it's mainly compute
and libraries uh and um whereas you know
obviously when you go to a company uh
that is directly going to customers then
it is a a slightly different uh
experience and I I kind of fancied the
idea of also building or being at a
company early on in the day, you know,
where things aren't fully defined, where
they need direction and there's the
opportunity to sort of build things from
the ground up. Um, and uh and I yeah and
and then of course I met you know Argy
the the co-founders or all the team
there and just amazing group of people.
Um again for transparency I'm sure
there's amazing group of people open a
nanthropic this is not in a dig at you
know any other uh company but uh but for
me the opportunity to work with with
Johannes who is also an academic he is a
professor we share the exact same
mindset of like we're really fastm
moving and and pushy and and like you
know we know what we want to do but
grounded in science and and rigor and
and openness uh and that sort of pro-
academic um pro publishing pro open
thing is so well aligned uh to myself.
So yeah, here I am. I guess uh the
advice maybe for others is that you
don't know where you're going to go. I
didn't have some grand plan that I'm
going to join an AI company, right? I
didn't even have a plan that I was going
to join a tech company. But looking to
continuously, I guess, push yourself and
be comfortable to take new challenges is
is worth it. And for sure, if you go
into a a large company, a sort of tech
company, I think you can learn so much.
It it doesn't mean that you can't
eventually go back to academia or
whatever, but I I'm still an advocate of
this scientific academic mindset
combined with industrial sort of
application.
So, so that's it. I know I've looking
like a clock here went on for half an
hour and so I hope that wasn't uh well
or maybe it helped you fall asleep. If
you listen to this to fall asleep, maybe
this did its job. But I just wanted to
share um a little bit of my story. I
hope again it just gives you a sense if
you're younger that don't worry if you
don't know exactly where you're going to
go as long as you you know have you know
what you want to do it what makes you
happy what what helps you to continue to
learn don't worry if you can't fully
chart out where you're going to go
there's a funny way that you can go from
place to place and and uh I wouldn't
stress sort of too much uh about it you
don't need to plan out your whole career
right from the
Um but be open to change and and be a
continual
learner. And I guess one thing maybe
okay I would say is and I'm biased. It's
nice if you can become a sort of expert
in something. I feel that that is always
going to help. You know there's nothing
wrong with being a generalist but I do
feel that if you can become a specialist
in an area it probably makes it easier
to chart a career path because you you
are known for a particular thing and I
feel that is probably hard to do without
having done a PhD or to be honest even a
posttock. Um obviously this is not
applicable to everybody but that would
at least be my um my personal uh advice.
There are many other ways of course and
it could be a specialist within your own
area right so it might be that you'll in
formula one but you become known as the
person who's like the AI engineering
expert within your formula one
discipline. I don't mean you have to,
you know, be then going to work for some
tech company or it could be in a in a
software company. You could just be
great uh that somebody who knows product
really well and you you become that that
person. All right. Well, um as you can
tell, I did slip a little bit with a few
episodes because uh all this change has
been a bit u been a bit busy. Uh but but
rest assured there is uh the podcast
will stay on track and I'll try and be a
bit better at getting these episodes out
more more regular. So if I can um help
if people have any questions on sort of
career or um things like that or just
general advice, feel free to leave a
comment. Uh probably on YouTube, I
guess. I think you can do it on Spotify,
but probably on YouTube and I'll try my
best to uh to to answer. So, I hope you
enjoyed that and uh wherever you are,
hope you're doing well. See you. [music]
[music]